We come to nimbin for peace and happiness
and harmony in our lives and the way
that we divided the labor in those
early days of building our homes
and establishing gardens was really
directed towards peace and harmony.
The difficulties
that would have ensued from say doing it
the other way around having the women out
trying to build the house and the
men inside looking out of the kids
that would not have been
a harmonious situation.
This didn't in any way allay the
deep suspicion of the city feminists
that we just fallen for
the old line and you know
that we were really not creating
any sort of alternative at all
but from our point of view it was a more
harmonious way of living our lives.
I think i can't speak for all
my sisters in that regard
but certainly for me
it didn't feel too bad
and i did have a go at clearing a
site and starting to build something
and within a very short space of time i was
weeping over the mattock i do you know
just feeling totally incompetent.
Now there were women who
who have built houses
and one woman built a stone
house at the top of a cliff.
From stone that she had
to get up there somehow.
And she devised a flying fox too to
carry the materials up to the site an
extraordinary feat of engineering
and another woman. Not only built.
I think by now she's built several houses
but in the in the early time of paradise
valley she built her first home
and subsequently went on to teach other
women in a women's building course and
and also taught aboriginal
women in a built. In course.
So that's not to say
that you know there weren't women who
became builders there were quite a few
but as i say in the early days it
was it was mainly the men who did
that sort of work and mostly
that was that was okay.
There were ways in which of
course you know i mean the guys
that came to live it turned
toward just guys you know
and the women were just women and
we all came with the conditioning
that we'd all had no different
from the rest of society
but with the haps a little more
will to move past our conditioning
and establish a new values
and customs for ourselves so
that the aim of
that was really to help each other rather
than to confront each other constantly
which would have just been a constant
battle. I think we were aiming for.
How can we co-operate how can
we live together better.
And there were many ways in
which we tried to achieve that.
No women's group was particularly supportive
of women you know who either wanted in
their relationship to improve
their status as women.
Or who felt
that their status was so far from any
hope of improvement in the relationship
that they were in that they were
supported then to get out of
that relationship because it was seen
as being destructive and harmful
and i guess for that reason
and also a lot of relationships
actually didn't survive.
And i do think that
that was partly because women were
supported to leave relationships
that was stifling them. Yeah very much.
So although it was a factor too.
In you'd think twice before leaving any
sort of a shelter because there wasn't
another one to go to easily and.
But because i suppose there were very
few women and quite a lot of guys
and probably about three to.
One in the first few years of tangible
it was a little easier for women to find
support not only among her women friends
but also from other guys
outside of her relationship.
And it didn't work the other way and
that led to an awful lot of loneliness
particularly among the guys who were there
without partners and
and really belied the myth
that the nimbin alternative society
was about sex drugs and rock
and roll because it was not as much about
sex as people might have supposed the
fact that we all ran around start naked
which we did had nothing to do with that.
Well certainly you know as far as i was
concerned it didn't it may have in the
minds of some people but. It really.
In a way there was a kind of incest
taboo operating where we were so close
and living together and
such close quarters that.
To run through a series of highly charged
sexual relationships with one's.
Brothers
and sisters could have actually been
destructive to the to the survival of the
community and you know i don't know how
conscious that was but i observed that
that it didn't happen
that there weren't a series of
highly charged sexual relationships
that one relationship
might be breaking down
and another one might be
passionately starting up but.
It was it wasn't right through the
community or you know sort of.
A total sort of day night loving as.
The media might have like to
portray it despite the fact
that we never had any clothes on.
It.
Very much so and in fact i think.
Had it not been for my tribal experience
of nimbin i may not have gone on to
be as interested in other
tribal cultures as i am but.
Subsequently i spent a great deal of time
with the rainforest tried since are awake
in borneo.
And particularly with the
penan and chi and tribes
and their ways of living exhibit often.
Well very much the same sort of qualities
and i've noticed also with
some aboriginal tribal people
and north american indians too.
That probably the most important things is
is if everybody's at a similar level of
poverty.
It's not really first was not really
experience just poverty then it's anything
that is extra to do your very
basic provisions is is a treat
and everybody is really excited about that
but also you share anything if everyone's
really poor you share anything with
anyone. There's no that smart and
you can't have it sort of feeling
and that's true throughout
tribal societies
and it's more true in truly tribal societies
than it was at nimbin in those days
but there were elements of that there
that you know there was there would
always be a welcome and refreshments
and you know hospitality even for
total strangers who arrived at tunde
or that somewhere they'd
always find a warm welcome
and a sense of community
as soon as they got there
and that's that's a very tribal
thing and a kind of integrity and.
A trust a lack of a
stranger feeling you know
that you're a stranger
somebody else is a stranger.
There's a kind of there's more openness
and trust accepting people exactly
as you find them at that moment
and not sort of projecting a whole
lot of fear or suspicion onto them.
And that tended to be you know.
The way that we operated it
for that everyone was okay
and if they prove
themselves to be otherwise.
Well we just knew more
about them than you know
and i think that's that's a
fairly tribal sort of thing.
And despite what i said earlier about
the ways of bringing up children still
within the tribal setting there were more
advantages for children than disadvantage
is that the tribal way of
bringing up children in the sense
that adults would have a sense of
responsibility as much for other people's
children as for their own now
that might have come back to
a lowest common denominator
that they didn't have much sense of
responsibility for anyone children
but the children all survived i mean none
of them actually sort of drowned in the
creek.
So there was a sense that there
were other eyes and ears and uncles
and aunties out there and if
you kids were in difficulty
that there be somebody they could
call on even if you weren't nearby.
That was a good feeling and a
tribal feeling but i think mostly
that the sense of a tribal experience came
when we came together for
celebrations and dances
and events could have been an event centered
around a spiritual activity such as
a naming ceremony for children or a
retreat or something of that sort
or it could have been just a full moon dance
at luna paul could have been anything
but when we all came together
and saw each other there in you know
dressed in whatever we're dressed in silks
and satins and colors and all that
sort of stuff in celebre tree mood.
Then the tribal sense was
exquisite just exquisite
and it's still it's still survives now
even they were scattered through the hills
and the rainbow region is extended far
beyond the boundaries of nimbin. When we do.
See each other at different events
maybe at byron bay or even in sydney
or somewhere else that sense of oh we're
together again is really wonderful
and now it's interesting because we often
i find with lots of different people.
We sort of make jokes about how we're all
going to end up in the same old hippies
home somewhere and i mean that it's a
joke now because we're in our mid forties
but actually 20 years down the track if we
keep meeting like this you know you know
what's going to happen
and it could well be
that there's a suddenly wonderful
eccentric old hippies home
and there's a part of me
that really hopes there will be i
think these they're just sort of.
You know.
Well the folk love was one of the very
earliest sort of institutions of nimbin i
mean there were many and and many
have survived to the present day
but the folklore was
particularly special because.
There were so many people who came who
had music as part of their background
and one of the things that they really
loved to do either is a you know.
A player or a listener.
And the folk club arose out of that
and arose also out of the fact
that a number of those people they
might have had classical training
or all sorts of training
and education in music a lot of them
were into writing original material
and which is not particularly commercial
perhaps but incredibly enjoyable
and so we had a weekly event where
you know it was just a kind of
jam session or you know people would would
play one at a time or into us or trios
or whatever and then all get together
at the end for whatever happened
and it was it was an extraordinary event
and every time it happened
i mean sometimes. It was.
The most astonishing music you know
and people you got to be very famous we
had people who sort of had played the
sydney opera house.
You know playing unbelievably strange
medieval instruments you know the night
before and the next night found themselves
in nimbin playing to an indian crowd
and getting you know an even more motorists
ponce in the night got at the opera
and we didn't we had a magic drawing power
for all sorts of people who came through
and one of the most healing events
for nimbin in the early days
when there was still
quite a bit of suspicion
and difficulty between the old settlers
and the new people who'd come to town
and slim dusty was in town and was
invited to play at the folk and
and agreed to do that
and it was just fantastic because he was
the hero of all the country people who
live there for ever
and you know particularly the sort of
middle aged country women who lived in a
minute that time you know just do it.
Him they were absolutely ecstatic slim dusty
fans quite unashamedly you know really
amazing. And and we organised a night
where half of it was slim dusty
and his daughter anka
patrick and their band
and putting on a fantastic totally
professional show for nothing.
You know and the rest of it was an info
club singers and the best of performance
and.
Who organised some special material for
the night to to really share with the old
settlers what it was that brings
us together and keeps us together
and to let them have a glimpse
of that and let them know
that they were welcome to
share in it too. Any time.
And it was just the most wonderfully
successful night. Everyone had a great time.
The old settlers of course loved
slim dusty and were you know.
Felt so wonderful to have him in
their town playing for them but.
Also really enjoyed that little peek into
what the hippies like to do you know
when they get in there on tuesday
nights and have their folk love
and you know they've never ventured
in before and to tell the truth.
They didn't venture in much after either
but it was they knew a bit more about us.
After that
and we'd had a a common shared high
experience which amongst ourselves we were
having all the time really regularly
but with the people who lived here
before we came we seldom got to have
that sort of commonality
of a high experience
that we could look back on together
and say wasn't that a great night
and it was lovely to have
one of those very special.
I never had any yeah i personally
never had any direct experience of
hostility from sickos who'd
been there before i came
but i heard of many people who did and
i was it was the nearest i got was
when somebody i was at the bush factory
one night and there was music on
and a neighbor complained
very loudly about the noise
and she obviously hated
everything about us.
It wasn't just the noise
at the factory that night.
Yes i did hear stories of
people being shot at it
when they were seen sort of diving into
some of these creek with no clothes on
and they were you know i mean it was a
period of adjustment in the first five to
eight years of living their lives.
You know understanding
that maybe it was offensive to other
people if we took our close off
and jumped in their creek.
You know and maybe we should think
about that and refrain. You know.
And the same time you know it was
offensive to us to see them lift a gun
and shoot at anything
you know especially us.
But you know even a bird or a rabbit a
lot. If people would have been very upset.
So you know i mean we just
had lifestyle differences
that were bound to bring some friction
but given the number of
those lifestyle differences
and the tenacity of people on both sides
to their particular way of life in some
cases it's surprising that there
wasn't more friction and there was
and i always feel like
you know looking back on
that applauding the old settlers for
their example of tolerance which i think
taught us a great deal and
when the time came for us to see a third
wave of settlers coming to nimbin who had
different ideals and look different and
acted differently from how we had.
We were very hard put to it
to show as much tolerance
and compassion as the
original settlers have been
when we are rived on their doorstep.
Here the study was i didn't study for the
university of new england i think as the
geography department. It
was a land use survey and.
The intention was to find out the shifting
patterns of land use in various parts of
new south wales i think they had
a control area somewhere else.
And they were particularly interested in
interviewing the new settlers to nimbin
and and finding out what they were about
and how what their intentions were as
regard the regards the use of the land.
Well i don't remember very much about
what they replied in answer to
that particular question
or that set of questions
but what really struck
me is quite remarkable.
Was that one of the questions that i ask.
I had to interview i
think it was 94 hippies.
Which wasn't hard to do it
was actually a lot of fun.
And one of the questions
that i asked them all was.
Whether they felt themselves in coming
to nimbin. To be a part of a movement.
And i mean objectively you know if you
took a step back and looked at it.
Who were 94 people representing another
you know several hundred who'd all come
around the same period of time
to the same area doing more
or less the same sorts of
things in similar ways
and you know from an objective point of
view movement wouldn't be too strong a word
to put on it but every one of them said
i'm not i'm not part of a movement.
I'm an individual who like it was
completely separate from anything else
that was happening and i found that quite
astonishing but it was actually true.
I mean people believed that
of themselves they felt.
They not only fat they really experienced
themselves as making a totally individual
choice and coming to nimbin and
doing a totally individual thing.
And i love the duology of that
that of course it was a movement
and of course it was nothing to do with a
movement it was a you know hundreds of
totally individual decisions.
I think that really a pit in
my eyes is a lot about women
and it says a lot about the difficulties
that we always had in making
rules for communities. You know.
Until falls coordination co-operative at
its very first tribal meeting brought up
the topic of whether people should
be allowed to have cats dogs
and guns on the property
and now 15 years later
and more than 58 in nearly 20 years later
they're still discussing whether they can
have cats dogs and guns
on the property and now
and all the intervening years there
have been cats and dogs and guns
and everybody's disapproved of it and
everybody's tried to make rules about it
and it can't happen. And so where
there are levels of agreement.
I think they're usually quite
unspoken and unconscious and.
Deviance from the general agreement
in terms of environmental
custodianship and those sorts of concepts
that are beyond rules. You know.
No i don't because i feel in a way
it's success because rigid rules
actively exclude the people
who will not conform to them
and in a society of non-conformists how
how could you possibly impose rigid rules
and not lose some of your best people.
It was about being active
being creative being careful
and being harmless
and it was also about growing ourselves.
Food children.
Institutions structures that we needed
that were appropriate to our needs.
But growing all those things and
taking care of those things
and as much as we could
of the wider picture too.
And giving something into it.
Putting own mark into it somehow
culturally so that involved music
and dance and poetry and all sorts of art
and. I suppose treading lightly on the
earth and and above all being harmless.
That's what it was for me
but you know they've be as many
visions as there are people here.
But he needs to.
Guys give it a serious.
Oh there's been so many stupid hippy ideas
and long hippy raves deep into
the night about to technology
and it's really hard to even think of
one example they are all so bizarre.
So bizarre that i can't i
can't come up with air
and. Well actually i mean in terms of
conspiracy theories that that that it.
There's been quite a frightening
thing about an imminent a way that
that there's a lot of paranoia
around and i don't know
that i really want to go into
that there because it's a i suppose only
a few individuals. So it's not a good.
It's not a good starting
at the end to go into
that.
Problem.
Yeah i think that's why i really didn't
want to go into it because there are there
are some people around them in who
will be thought disordered with
or without marijuana who are actually
you know borderline personalities
and that's really harry's area
more than mine. It's not a good.
It's not a good thing for me to talk
about yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah.
Kids names.
What people.
Yeah yeah.
Well people you people gave
their children the names
that people gave to their children were
actually no funnier than the names
that they gave to themselves.
I mean you know there were as many
sort of staff flowers and sundays
and moon shines in among the adult population
who changed their names as there were
strange and unusual
names for the children.
And of course particularly
when quite a few people became devotees
of racial nation and that's not to say
that that was any kind of dominant
paradigm in the community
but quite a few people did
get into the rajneesh eating
and take on new names as a result of
that there was impossible to remember
and far too long and irrelevant.
But that's a judgment of mine but the nays
that were given to children because
a lot of the children wouldn't.
Wouldn't keep they once they got to school
age if the name embarrassed them the
child would change it.
I was there was a there was a child called
tiger who pretty quickly reverted to
sally when she got to school and
there was another little guy.
I forget what his original name was
but i member he ended up
being he was known as diddy.
He's known as diddy and that was
his name and he became john.
Very quickly.
And i remember one frenchman who
didn't name his child at all
and wouldn't give her name and
she was three when i measure
and so don't have a name but i
don't know what became of her
and i can't remember her name.
Oh. I think for me the most
memorable night was was.
Well there were several there
were several memorable night.
There was one in particular
that was a new year's eve which traditionally
was held as a sort of costume ball a
blue knob hall.
And a hippie costume ball is something
to be seen it was really fantastic
and on this particular night it was
especially wonderful for me because i knew in
advance
that some people coming over from america
whom i greatly admired stephen gaskin
and his wife i am a gaskin who had set up
a community in tennessee called the farm
and was him i'd been in correspondence
for several years by then
and they were coming to the area to
visit i knew they were due any day
but what actually happened was
that we were all at the dance i
do know a pool on new year's eve
and stephen gaskin and i know may
arrive just as smiling ruth and
and the band i think the band was
called blue skies or something
and they just started to
play the tennessee waltz
and by sheer coincidence steven and
i am a arrived at you know of hall
and you know i recognized
even from a distance.
I was outside the hall and here i've
and i was standing facing him in the
moment when he first heard the music
and realized what the song was and
he realized that the tennessee vols.
Is being played and i realized that
he was steven gaskin from tennessee
and then we looked at each other and
we just had this incredible hug
that we never met before but
it was incredibly high.
It was a wonderful experience
and he went on to to spend a few weeks
around nimbin and it was a great visit
and a great cultural exchange.
I think there are certain parts of
the world that have a magic energy.
I don't i couldn't define.
It any better than that it's it's an energy
that you feel as you approach a place.
It might magnetize you it
could repel you i suppose
but you know it's a feeling
that you get about play.
And women has a very
strong spirit of place
and i couldn't possibly define it
but for me it's absolutely
unmistakably there and.
I know
that there are other people who experience
other parts of the world as having a
similar. Vibration if you like
and i think it's a you know it's to do
with the things that have happened there.
The history of the place.
I don't think those sorts of
emanations disperse very easily
and you know there are
there's a sort of cold dank
and nasty feeling about places where cold
dank and nasty things have happened.
And there's a an energetic feeling about
places where energetic things have
happened and nimbin is certainly one
of those things and i've got to go.
Yea.